everybody we're celebrating the happy
place issue of Drew magazine which are
also feel oh my God feature some of my
favorite true's news story including a
blurb about this non-alcoholic French
champagne from a company called French
Bloom let's sip some bubbly while we do
this
[Music]
[Applause]
really really good all right well first
up Insider reports that Hugh Grant
recently said that movie sets are so
weird now because everyone's always
looking at their smartphones and in the
old days by the end of the second week
you were all getting drunk in the
evening and having dinner and falling in
love with each other he is not wrong
really oh my gosh is that what it's like
on a movie set oh yeah 100 it's so much
fun like it used to be
um he says that all that stopped because
everyone goes home and they're on social
media or at work they're sort of just
like down in their phones yeah he's
right actually I don't think it's just
on movie sets though I mean I used to
work at Lane Bryant in the mall hi to my
friends and it was like break time was
the fun time because we all talk smack
and we plan going out later that night
this is before phones right you
understand I'm old okay I I don't know
it was like basically it was like that
camaraderie and I think that's what he's
saying what they're missing now because
everyone's in here who here feels like
you know maybe we're looking down at our
phones more than we are engaging with
people put your hands up if you think
that's the truth okay almost everyone in
the audience but you know what's
interesting while we're on our phones
we're all searching for connection you
know what I mean you're checking Twitter
or you're swiping to find a date but
there's someone there's people right in
front of you but we're not connecting
with them isn't that interesting I wish
does anyone know what we could do have a
suggestion no this gentleman over here
Joey and you okay great we'll hit both
yes please
um I just think we should start randomly
talking to people like I talked to him
on my flight to my bachelorette now
we're friends
really and yeah and the other day I was
at the grocery store
help the mom download an app to her
phone and we're hanging out later this
week just talk to people
[Music]
okay what is your name I'm sorry what is
your name my name is Ida Ida yeah I love
you and I love that you have this living
proof right next to you of a struck up
conversation and a connection leads to
the two of you hanging out here today
not only that but
um I met her through a friend we're
married now so yeah
well no swiping involved old school okay
great and then this gentleman over here
Joey he had a black vest on he's in the
second row what is your suggestion and
name uh play more board games I love
board games board games are great
uh I do a lot of painting so I meet
people playing board games in real life
at a board game Cafe
[Applause]
Board Game Cafe what's your name Travis
Travis Travis I love you too yeah Board
Game Cafe you have my uh that yes yes
yes and thank you you guys thank you
that gives me hope let's all try to make
a friend someone new
all right anybody here remember
Blockbuster Video we all know well of
course yeah well Fox Business uh reports
they may be back in Action apparently
the movie rental chain recently updated
their website with this message it just
said please be kind while we rewind
also their Twitter account has been
active as well so we're not sure what's
going on Blockbuster Video was
originally founded back in 1985 and
reached its peak in like 2009 with 9 000
locations but now there's only one
blockbuster left and it's in Bend Oregon
by the way really yeah I mean are we it
was the most fun on a Friday to go to
Blockbuster like split up with your
friends or family and be like you pick
one I pick one let's meet May the best
man win debate it
finally in Drew magazine we have a page
dedicated to Small Wonders about
different ways that we can help our tiny
animal friends and in this issue we
suggest maybe I don't know adopt a sloth
by supporting the sloth conservation
Foundation but before we do that
everybody if you'll um get quiet with me
because somebody doesn't love loud
noises welcome David misajewski and
puppy the sloth a live sloth I'm gonna
keep it together
hi everyone it's okay we don't have to
be super super quiet why don't you guys
come on out here oh my God oh my God
both of you a sloth of your own to hold
from the National Wildlife and is it
because you want to pacify us from
grabbing puppy it is a little bit
because I know he's irresistible so you
guys this is a two-toed sloth they live
down in South America they're called
sloth because they move very slowly
let's see if we can get them to eat yes
you can see he's gonna just kind of
nibble on this
why are they like that where can I get
some of that well because the food that
they eat is actually not very nutrient
dense and so they have to eat a lot of
this leaf and plant material and they
digest it very very slowly and so they
don't have a lot of energy and moving
slow actually helps them avoid Predators
most of their weight is actually in the
food in their stomach because they eat
so slowly they only go to the bathroom
about once a week and about 60 percent
of their weight goes away so and they
also tend to not smell they're like a
little bit scentless and they're really
really lovely I'll tell you what those
those two toes if you can see hooked on
my neck here oh hi they're pretty sharp
someone needs a pedicure hi they're
pretty sharp but he's a two-toed sloth
on their front toes they've got those
two claws there's another kind called a
three-toed that has three so you know
yeah kind of obvious there yeah but I
brought him on here today because I
really wanted to give a message about
Wildlife Conservation it's what we do
with the National Wildlife Federation
and this is what's at stake we're in a
wildlife Extinction crisis on this
planet and it's not just happening in
South America where he lives but it's
happening right here in the U.S and so
we eat everybody out there to use your
voice to get involved join groups like
The National Wildlife Federation like
the soft conservation fund because if we
all care and we all take a little bit of
action we can save these guys oh
are you and I'm in we'll do whatever
why did they sort of why is the world
like this to them because they're about
to hang upside down so being backwards
like that in you know in the wild and
and you know he hangs from those claws
like this so that's a normal position
for him and Rossi didn't you guys meet
back when you were hosting Chelsea
Lately we did we've met before yeah I
was hosting Chelsea Lately but none of
look at that picture okay see that was
me being very brave all right that was
the hardest segment I've ever done
because I was trying so hard not to
laugh because you were hilarious I'm
trying to like give Wildlife info and
Ross is like making me crack up so yeah
sorry about it but that's why you
brought a sloth this time just to Slow
Me Down
David and puppy I cannot thank you
enough because I want everyone to head
to our websites and all our socials
would be pushing to show you how you can
be more a part of the effort to save
sloths and other uh wildlife and um
thank you so much Dave for bringing
puppy here
and up next we're gonna go to someone
else's happy place and there are
dumplings there because you know that
that well say no more
[Music]
foreign